[Music]  you're the one who matters  i'm gonna go swim with zelda  [Music]  newest endeavor is a chip implanted into  couples  brains to merge their thoughts hazel and  i  are users one our minds  will be one technology has improved the  way we live  why not improve the way we love  together we will become a singular  living god i want it out  and i want a divorce  what happened in there it's a lot to  explain  [Music]  planes shotguns acting like you're  running for your life  hazel have you ever thought of just  lowering your standards in terms of  general happiness he's watching us  right now for a shift that he implanted  in my brain  i've been working on this my whole life  i don't know what i want  but i know i don't want you  you can't merge she'll die but she won't  there  you like what you see yeah  you wanna get a little closer let's get  right in there  you like that you see who are you  talking  i know that's why i asked  [Music]  bye